Jurassic world fallen Kingdom is
directed by Jay a Bayona the man behind
the impossible the orphanage and a
monster calls terrific director really
like his work and it's once again
written by Colin Trevorrow and Derrick
Connolly who wrote the first and when
the volcano on Isla Nublar begins to
erupt threatening the extinction of all
the dinosaurs that were made on that
island
Owen and Claire mount a campaign to
return to the island and rescue the
dinosaurs from a second extinction I
wasn't a huge fan of Jurassic world it
was better than Jurassic Park 3 it had
some characters that I liked and had a
few entertaining moments and a good
score but overall it was a disappointing
movie for me
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom is
something I was excited for because of
the director because when you make a
film that isn't quite as good as it
could be you are normally able to learn
from some of those mistakes and try to
make a better film as a result and in
this case we had a new director and I
was thinking that's what they were going
to do also the trailers show Ian Malcolm
played by Jeff Goldblum and that's
always a wonderful sight to see and I
like all the acting talent involved with
this film for the most part and so I was
pretty excited I left the theater very
disappointed even more disappointed than
I was with Jurassic world this film did
a lot of things wrong and very little
right in all honesty my friends and I
sat around after the movie talking for a
couple hours at a nearby restaurant and
the conversation we had was more than
just nitpicking they weren't just like
fanboys sitting there disappointed that
we didn't get another movie like
Jurassic Park I actually really liked
the lost world thing The Lost Worlds
very unique sequel different than the
first did fun things had amazing set
pieces a fantastic score by John
Williams and a great performance by Jeff
Goldblum and I really like Vince Vaughn
and Julianne Moore in that film there's
a lot to like in a lost world Pete
Postlethwaite that's how you say his
last name rest in peace Roland what a
great character Jurassic world didn't
have anything that felt that way to me
it didn't have much to feel like grand
about it didn't have any memorable
sequences fallen Kingdom has even less
this film makes a choice about halfway
through to become a different type of
film now this was actually a surprise to
because after the first trailer I didn't
watch anymore because everyone said they
were very spoilery and they are now that
I've seen the film and went back and I
watched the final trailer 95% of the
movie is in that trailer it's kind of
sad actually but I'm glad I didn't watch
it so I didn't know what this film does
about halfway through so most of you who
have seen these trailers do and so I'm
going to give you a mild spoiler warning
if you do not know what happens after
the volcano erupts that we've all seen
in that first trailer I'm about to talk
about where the film goes after that and
I don't really consider this a spoiler
since the trailers have shown it it's
the halfway point of the movie and it's
really where the film's plot actually
gets in motion and where the film
absolutely tanks a rich older man is
near death he's played by James Cromwell
and he feels responsible in a way and so
he is funding this team that goes to the
island to retrieve the dinosaurs to put
them on like a sanctuary but in reality
they're going back to this mansion and
there's some evil greedy corporate
schemes that's happening there and the
rest of the film takes place in this
mansion it basically becomes a monster
movie in a big house this could be
awesome the orphanage is a very good
horror film I love it the direction is
far better than the screenplay which I
found very messy and almost completely
devoid of wit or interesting characters
when you look back at the first Jurassic
Park a lot of people talk about the
dinosaurs and how great the dinosaurs
are and it's a fun movie but really the
things that I remember the most about
that movie were the conversations the
debate around that table about whether
or not the dinosaurs should really be
brought back to life or if it was a
giant mistake or if it was a positive
thing Alan Grant coming to terms with
how he views dinosaurs the Raptor claw
that he throws out of his pocket when
he's in a tree with the children he's
able to leave that part of his life
behind and focus on the future there's
so much character in that movie plus
awesome dinosaurs this film is just
dinosaurs creeping out of the shadows
and that's it if you aren't a big fan of
Jurassic Park or the lost world or that
or this franchise if you don't feel like
you care that much then
you might enjoy the film because it's a
lot of sequences with dinosaurs and
people running but it's basically like
the last 15 minutes of the lost world
except stretched forever and in one spot
let's talk about the characters Chris
Pratt as Owen likable it's Chris Pratt
but his character has no development
from the beginning of this film he
hasn't changed at all since the last and
by the end of this film he still hasn't
changed there's barely any development
for his character if any at all Clare is
a bit better than she was in Jurassic
world she doesn't just make mistake
after mistake after mistake
Ian Malcolm's in the film for a little
bit and besides that that's about where
the likable characters ended for me and
I found pretty much everyone else
insufferable the villains are cartoon
characters that just want money greedy
corporate people that want money which
was so disappointing and so overused the
whole dinosaurs as military weapons
subplot actually comes back despite the
fact that I don't remember a single
person after seeing Jurassic world
saying yeah that was a really good idea
militarized Raptors there's a reason
that you don't see the army in today's
actual world training lions or Tigers
but once again we're back to that
subplot for some reason there's a
character named Franklin Webb who is a
young kid who works at a call center
with Bryce Dallas Howard who goes to the
island despite his incredible fear of
getting on a plane he's afraid of
everything he's prone to panic attacks
but he's there basically to access some
of the computer technology despite the
fact that Clair used to run the whole
park and she should be able to access
everything herself she has to have this
buddy of hers from a call center go
who's afraid of virtually every sound
and he screams and he cries for the
entire film couldn't stand him could not
believe they actually wrote a character
like that in this movie could you
imagine like in the lost world for
instance Ian Malcolm's young daughter
she's a little bit scared you know but I
wouldn't exactly say she was annoying at
least she actually does something say
what you want about the gymnastics
moment it's like 12 seconds of the movie
and it's sort of out of place but at
least she actually does something
this character Franklin Webb is just
there for comic relief why do you need a
comic relief when you have Chris Pratt
Chris Pratt's very funny
you don't need another comic relief
character especially when that character
is insufferable
at the beginning of the film is a moral
dilemma do we save these creatures from
extinction do they have that right since
they were created by man in a lab and
the film basically talks about it for
maybe two minutes and then just glosses
it over entirely Ted Levine's character
is completely wasted he's in the film to
go her I'm Ted Levine and that's about
it he has one scene that you think is
going to be really awesome but no in
regards to violence the film is almost
bloodless it doesn't seem to have any
guts like you know no pun intended but
it just doesn't really seem like they
really wanted to push that boundary like
they're so afraid of showing kids
anything remotely violent I'm just
remembering Jurassic Park and Samuel
Jackson's bloody stump of an arm on
Ellie Sattler shoulder and there's
nothing like that in this movie it's so
tame which was a major disappointment as
well
there's no remarkable sequences in the
first film you'd have that amazing t-rex
breakout and it feels like it builds as
soon as the power goes out to that last
shot of the t-rex roaring that whole
like 20 minutes just feels like it's
building and building and building to
this amazing crescendo even in the lost
world with the trailer dangling over the
cliff and the two t-rex is the baby
t-rex all of that feels like it's
building and building it's great fun
there's nothing like that in this film
or in Jurassic world it's just a bunch
of scenes that have dinosaurs I don't
really recall any remarkable moments in
this movie which is so sad the CGI is
admittedly very impressive and they've
done some incredible things there's a
great sequence with a animatronic blue
the Raptor that was very impressive but
beyond the money that's being thrown at
the screen there's nothing to take away
there's no emotional core there's no
interesting conversation
to have it's just a dinosaur monster
movie which is just so bland the film
feels like a placeholder like it was
made just to make the next one like we
wanted to make this one just so
eventually we could have what we want to
do soon and that's just what it feels
like it feels like a necessary film like
it's just a filler movie or something
which is just why I mean it's Jurassic
Park and you can ask me what did you
expect it's a dinosaur movie what did I
expect
Jurassic Park is one of my all-time
favorites it's a classic I expect
something at least moderately close to
that there are some very specific things
I want to talk about but they are
definitely spoilers and so I'm gonna
save that first for the review which I
will publish in a few days because I
have to talk about them but there are
some decisions made towards the end of
this film that just it blows my mind in
regards to stuff that characters do I
didn't hate this movie it's too
good-looking and and too well made from
a directorial standpoint for me to hate
it
but from a story standpoint from a
screenplay standpoint this movie is a
colossal mistake
it has pointless visual callbacks to the
first Jurassic Park film that are so on
the nose it was very obvious it follows
a very similar plot as the lost world it
even has a few scenes that feel straight
out of Jurassic Park 3 a Jurassic Park 3
used to be my least favorite film in
this franchise but I got to be real with
you I think I'd rather watch 3 over this
again for a few reasons
3 doesn't mess with the continuity of
the others this film kind of does it
makes you hate other characters from the
others by telling you decisions they
apparently made once that make no sense
also Jurassic Park 3 is only like 92
minutes long or something with credits
and this films over 2 hours one last
thing and I'm ending the review with
this for a reason because Trevorrow has
stated that while he is not necessarily
wiping the lost world and Jurassic Park
3 from Canon with his film Jurassic
world he chose not to acknowledge them
apparently they're still in Canon but he
chose not to acknowledge them now if
they're still in Canon
which they should be that means that is
law Sorna exists the volcano is on Isla
Nublar now according to Canon all of the
dinosaurs that were on Isla Sorna were
moved to Isla Nublar when Jurassic world
finished construction but ezel Sorna is
still an island without a volcano that's
active so why make some elaborate move
the dinosaurs to mainland when you can
just move them to Isla Sorna well I know
why because they want to make Jurassic
world 3 I'm gonna give Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom a c-minus I could give it
a lower grade I really could but the
film is extremely well directed with
some really amazing visuals which
unfortunately most of you have seen the
trailer already but I didn't but now
that I went back and watch the trailer
I'm like holy I feel bad for the
internet for seeing all that but yeah I
definitely want to talk about a lot in a
spoiler video so look forward to that
very soon guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you liked
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes I'll tell you the
problem with the scientific power that
you're that you're using here it didn't
require any discipline to attain it you
know you read what others had done and
you and you took the next step you
didn't earn the knowledge for yourselves
so you don't take any responsibility for
it you're stood on the shoulders of
geniuses to accomplish something as fast
as you could and before you even knew
you had you you've patented it and
packaged it and slapped it on a plastic
lunch box and now selling wanna sell it
well
[Music]